so this is true all right so you know
how I said before I've yet to see an
episode where I'm really annoyed by
Lemongrab but he does he I think I found
the episode I think this finally did it
for me but with that said it's not it's
not annoyed or is it just dislike it
can't it be both okay let's start with
the start the story here Oh Ben still
kind of an idiot like really retreading
old water here like okay so since he's
broken up or dumped by Flame Princess
she he goes with bubblegum to the the
lemon Kingdom is that what's called the
lemon whoa hold on Oldham it's a one of
them people keep yelling at us because
we always say it the wrong way
the he's it because he's uh yes is the
Earl of Lemongrab Yeah right yeah all
right the lemon place in quotes which
means that it can be interpreted however
you want I'll do my best to remember
what people write down yes so I will not
because my memory is like that I know
yes I know they know that at least I
remember so they go to that they go to
this place that pretty much just as like
a dinner or something just so I'm making
sure really what was it just sort of a
what was it actually just kind of like a
bank it seemed like it was some sort of
state dinner diplomats day yeah that's a
say yeah well I gives us some sort of
diplomatic dinner though mostly just she
seemed to be the only one not from there
um but but she created them so I guess
it makes sense uh and if Finn is looking
to maybe sort of get a relationship
going with bubblegum again which is I
can't roll my eyes at that like you know
come on didn't we do this but you know
okay so it goes in there's the last time
we saw the lemongrabs he ate one you
he ate one of him and now there's a
giant one and half of one with a giant
bite out of him so I guess we're kind of
assuming like the other one kind of
survived a little bit of her yeah how he
got out I don't want to know so there he
is and with me he acts like Lemongrab
and the place is still scary as hell and
comes across this bubblegum comes across
this little boy named with a lemon hoop
yes yes and was put in prison just for
you know it kind of being different and
playing the harp and bubblegum wants to
take him away to the Candy Kingdom where
you know he can be cleaning yeah you
play math and you can have fun he can be
a little kid and she can help him grow
but that's unacceptable so Finn and
bubblegum tried to play a prank like
they did the first time to came across
Lemongrab too young yeah in too young
and it backfires on Finn but it was
actually going exactly according to plan
towards bubblegum because you want them
from an imprisoned and then lenda hope
can play the flute that causes the
lemongrabs to come in and free them
because they like the music so much even
though it sounds terrible and long story
short they finally they they find a way
to escape all the other lemon people
want after their release from the old
collar things want
lemonhope to get away to sort of be the
you know like the one who got out pretty
much you know just the one to go out and
live a good life and come back for them
that's how you can make Lemongrab funny
put in
I'd say guy you could put them in a lot
of film roles but we're really getting
awesome because that can go on forever
okay thanks just doing my favorite
things up about that movie Titanic I'll
never let go let's go no not just that
it's the I'll never let go oh I always
wanted to see when she takes the whistle
huh but guys about this teeth are still
wrong so why don't you like Lemongrab in
this one why are you annoyed I think
it's I don't know where the other ones
really had that let's finish up - uh
Finn finally realizes that he cannot be
with bubblegum that age really is more
than number in this case and that he
should try to patch things up with Flame
Princess so you know duh I mean it kind
of a no-brainer but you know whatever
I like though that he's actually has to
learn the lesson it's not just something
that is a natural thing it said oh
that's gonna work out
welcome back to my first love but then
he kind of I don't know did he kind of
learn this already
he's got learning it again yeah I don't
know well I don't know what is going on
with him hormones whoa no no no no he is
okay you know I I I really don't get it
because okay especially being 14 and
especially you know being someone who's
kind of had his heart broken with
bubblegum and then he's got this great
thing going Flame Princess he up
but then I don't know she leaves him he
doesn't dump her so whether it be like
some morning or something I mean would
it be kind of sad it wouldn't be
something kind of land he just goes
immediately at least you know that's
yeah it's trying to get this old flame
no pun intended
and of course she's not gonna be
interested because we've already
established that we've done this and
we've stated the exact reason why again
so you so think back everyone that was
they got dumped or dumped someone they
didn't immediately start dating someone
else they actually went through a
mourning phase oh jeez some people do I
don't know kids do nowadays people don't
even do that at our age
oh no no no but that's also a difference
to how long we've been together
that's the devil you know but no I agree
with that but with that said I don't
think her I don't think him in flame
princess were just like oh they just
started dating and they're kind of
getting to know each I said they they
seem like they know each other pretty
well
enough to put personal things in there
that only he would know
you know that they got a pretty tight
relationship then uh you know and
they're pretty close it feels just so
many they stated a couple times at
whatever you came across a bump in the
road yeah I can understand going to
someone even honestly going back you
know there's someone either like
bubblegum or trying to find someone
different I can kind of see too but the
fact that there's no like it doesn't hit
him at all but I think that's kind of
the point is that it's done and over
with he was hurt and he was like okay
instead of dealing with the hurt and the
suffering I'm gonna quickly jump into
some other relationship so I don't have
to deal with any of that so that didn't
seem like the focus it seemed much more
like he just really wanted to get
bubblegum he's like huh maybe I should
try to patch things up I mean it was
like it seemed very emotionless and I
came out to my point is that he's trying
to hide and get away from emotion do you
think they're really do you think I was
really being shown though I mean I don't
know it's like it I hate going back to
being a child instead of being his
actual age the whole time that they're
together it's it's like a shot for that
shot for shot but it's like completely
harkening back to to young yeah I mean
even sense you know yeah like the old
things you know I think he's trying to
ignore what he has that feeling these
feelings and immediately going back to
the younger times when he was happy
running around just pulling pranks
instead of having to deal with what's
actually going on I
you know if they did something like well
first of all you know I could see maybe
if like he tried to recreate it so much
they like maybe he tried to make her 13
again or something like that no like
that would really show no that would
show the impression that would show the
obsession that he is not ready to let
this go that he is like he cannot move
on and he cannot accept what happened
here it just sir seems like and when
tears come on like things are cool right
things are cool it's like I think if it
seems like it had to go one step further
in order to show the real to show what
he's running from Oh see I didn't see
that to me notice even he's here Oh even
seeing one Lemongrab half-eaten and the
little boy being kicked
lemonhope getting kicked and his
instrument you know trashed and when
they're about to be attacked he what
he's getting attacked by them you never
fought back this whole episode he was
half-hearted nothing he did did he do
with any fall intention of doing
anything and that's what I'm saying
nothing he did was like himself normally
he'd be fighting normally he'd be trying
to save the day he'd be punching these
people back he'd see stuff going on
they'd be like wait this isn't right I
should help out Dino he sits down he
says you know what let's pull a prank
how do you think that's I mean I saw
that too
but that it felt more to me like you
know oh well this is just him trying to
get back to this but it didn't feel like
out of the the ignoring of the true
motions going on it sound like a
whatever but the true motions that you
know would most likely be going on for
his character it seemed like they just
weren't addressing it which I know is
part of the point like well yeah he
wasn't address he he would just ignore
it but it by the whole episode kind of
ignoring it I feel like it's just the
epi'
if he ignores it fine the episode
ignoring it I think is a problem
I think they should show that this is
not being looked at and that's a problem
that he's really not looking at it where
instead they're showing trying to
recreate the old days is not a good idea
the focus should have been not
addressing the emotions that you're
feeling about playing
princess is the issue maybe they'll be
in the next one you know there may be a
will but think about it - he lies to his
best friend
- hurting Jake's feelings not only is he
lying to Jake he's lying to hurt his
feet not not specifically to hurt his
feelings but I mean oh yeah she told
hates you she hates you and then when it
is time to save the day
and flame Christmas is like we have to
call Jake we need to oh yeah yeah sorry
bubblegum and no that's all right that's
right he'd rather have all hell break
loose than have to worry about calling
Jake and explaining to Jake that you
know the princess doesn't hate you I
just lied because I want for whatever
reason decided that this is the new tail
I'm gonna chase I was very unhappy with
him I think if they had the obsession
that I'm not against the obsession I'm
not even against trying to go back to
create the the glory days because you're
right I think a kid even if you say even
a dolt would kind of try to do that
especially after being with someone that
they felt so close to but I think by
just by the episode ignoring those
emotions I think we missed something and
I think it's it it didn't feel
intentional that maybe it was but I'm
trying to look at even if that was her
at the point it's like I want to see it
just makes him look shallow and jerky
well what kind of what he is though at
this point in time that's kind of what
he is I think he's no I think he is a
good kid and any you know he is a hero
knee and he said really really you know
good thoughts for other people he wants
to help people and stuff like that and
he wants to do what's best for himself
and others uh so I can't see him just
trade-up ignoring this and just acting
like well this is normal I can see him
ignoring it and then realizing this is
really a problem I should address this
and this is bad I've caused some bad
stuff we're in this one sir like you
know where it's I don't know it's I
thought the COPE gone further with it
see in to me I guess looking back at
anything even friends fighting or
whatnot if they tried to turn it into
some obsession that's different than
what most people
go through wanting to go back and kind
of relive err try to reignite with an
old flame or whatever it's not
necessarily an obsession it's just kind
of longing for simpler times longing for
better times where things weren't as
complicated as they are now and I think
drawing more attention to it like
focusing on that I think would make it
even more awkward or more bizarre or
more stranger not as natural to this I
see him having a fight with a friend and
say fine I'm not gonna I'm not gonna
hang out with you I'm gonna hang out
with blank because I used to have more
fun with them beforehand when we played
Tonka toys okay so you know the bag and
you hang out with the person playing
talking toys and they're like dude I
don't play this stuff anymore I'm kind
of done with that I've moved on and then
he's like ah crap you're kind of right
you know what I need to fix up my
friendship and that's what he does with
Jake he says to Jake yeah I need to fix
what's going on the Flame Princess okay
even when you just did there though by
saying you know if there was a scene
where he's trying to talk with Flame
Princess if she won't answer he yells
fine you know what I'm gonna go with
bubblegum because that's that's what I
remember those are the good say that
that at least would be him showing some
emotion showing some remorse even that's
just for a couple seconds you know but
but you don't get any of that say I
didn't need that though I kind of to me
I guess it was implied like for me it
was just like I kind of accepted that
that's what's going on like he said at
the end of what's my call it uh Frost
and Fire yeah he's like you know I blew
it I screwed up I messed up and she says
I need time alone and I don't know like
I guess if we saw him trying to call he
would look desperate and pathetic as
compared to someone who's just trying to
move on or try to ignore what he's
feeling but that but that is desperate
through it but it is desperate pathetic
I'm not arguing that and I think the I'm
guessing of course they weren't going
for the desperate and pathetic route
they were going for so who's just trying
to ignore the past or ignore what just
happened and trying to go back to a
simpler time I'm just guessing you know
I think especially after writing the
last episode with him saying such
hurtful things to say yeah this episode
be right after
it's I can't quite see working the other
way either but to have this be
immediately after that it just they
don't go well together in making him
well there was an episode in between
that probably would have been a little
bit smoother yeah or even I was saying
to maybe there's an episode after that
sure shows the morning and how he
screwed up and how it affects them which
is like if they do that fair enough you
know at least fair addressing it but I
really feel there should have been
something even if it's just for a few
seconds you know like what you just said
there of him trying to talk with her and
then just say you know heck with it
maybe you could make something funny out
of it but just showing that there what
that emotion was there and he was
confused by it and now he's taken this
route by just starting out in that route
and never addressing them yet will hurt
that he went through and not letting us
see the hurt at all seen I saw that at
the end when he decided when he said at
the end I really need to patch things up
with Flame Princess just the way he said
it he's like I screwed up I really need
to patch things up with her and he's
like other too bad charity guys a
girlfriend she's sweet she's like what
like I'm just kidding it's like oh I got
hurt in the emotion right there just
from okay I mean they're fair and I did
I needed more but I like you say to you
you felt like it was very it was very
much implied it was much more so all
that way said somebody good I do like
the idea I like the idea of trying to go
back here you live you know you said the
old things the glory days you know
thinking that well no this person had
this or they all I need is this element
but it's it's not the things it's not
the people you know it's himself a beats
to change yeah so I did like that idea a
lot uh and I'm not a gift though like I
said it's just the tentacles of it oh no
I mean finish kind of be an ass hmm and
it's just kind of it yeah he's kind of
being an ass but that's been now if you
used to it oh well let me talk a little
bit about the lemon Greg is that's when
I started off in this episode where so I
should probably end with her why why he
annoyed me in this one um I think
there's just me maybe it is the delivery
maybe it's just a little too much of him
but there's something about in this one
when he was
some of the youngest screaming did still
make me live you know my PUD you know I
liked the port IV that was very funny
but mate maybe I'll finally just getting
too used to the screaming and I'm the
the fresh delivery of what inflections
he would emphasize at which once he
would not and how long you would
emphasize it and even in the one vowel
where he would emphasize to I mean like
you would just never know where that
voice was gonna go and it's feeling
predictable now and I maybe that's the
reason why and it's sudden like I said
and some things I liked seemed Becky I
love seeing that weird or whatever and
there's definitely some good laughs in
it too but yeah I think this was fine at
the point where it's like I think I'm I
think I'm kind of getting done with what
do you think though it could be because
the rest of everybody else in the
kingdom was doing the lemongrass voice I
don't think so no cuz actually them I
didn't mind too much and maybe because
he was I don't I don't worry different
versions of a Lemongrab type voice um
they didn't bother me too much actually
in fact I liked it when they were when
the collars were gone they were stacking
up trying to get I'm trying to get was
it let me know
lemonhope I like that and I kind of fell
for them to you know like they're that
no we're gonna help you please just go
make something be something you know
we're gone we got that but you don't
have to be a knight I sort of felt that
I serve actually Lejeune we felt that um
and I'd seen Lemongrab a jerk before you
know so I I don't know it's like his
level I mean I was debating that too
it's like is it because he was just so
mean and so unlikable it's like he's
been pretty mean and unlikable before
but yeah there's just no something about
this one sinister I mean he's eating his
own twin Ennis but he got into that
before no we laughed I know but in this
part though he's getting fat off of his
twin who is now I mean not just okay so
we find out that he's been created and
he's kind of a weird fellow he just
wants people around him so people's
creates another of him
for him oh my god happiness ensues well
not really because they start to create
more and more and more people he likes
giving life and creating life and all
that stuff but now what happens he no
longer cares about giving life it's all
about him eating all the food I was just
gonna say it used to be he would do
stuff wrong and angriest up a he was
doing it for what he thought was the
right reason here he clearly knows this
is not the right reason he's just being
a jerk and with the graybles when he
eats his brother the thing is with the
graybles it's a is it real is it not
real yeah oh these kind of stories so
it's kind of like what you saw it was
kind of go my god that's funny and
that's crazy but now you see the
aftermath that crap that happened he
actually ate part of his brother
including part of his head and he's got
huge and he's stealing from everyone's
plates yes I think you're right he's
just he's just one boy yes one brother
takes the bread just hands it over even
though he's completely like skin bones
pretty much he still cares about the
actual citizens and in the end he asleep
I accepted ones are acceptable you know
and then he's consistently kicking the
little kid he destroys his harp and then
kicks in two or three times I mean no
like Lemongrab has become like evil like
an evil ass an evil greedy jackass yeah
I I think it's sort of a mix where it
used to be I think part of it is time
has passed and I'm just so getting used
to the voice and the other is that yeah
um that he is such an evil person I mean
he's like your traditional villain
yeah um because I'm saying to myself if
you start off with that with this
character like whatever episode 1 or 2
you know or whatever it's like I'd still
probably laugh at him because the
delivery is so strange and how he's such
a child he would kick you know the boy
over and stuff but yeah I think because
I've gotten so used to the voice and
he's just so unlikable now because
before was like ignorant yeah you know
and he knows what's going on ya know
what about the one thing you noticed in
the bathroom
yes I was gonna talk about that I'm sure
other people knows this to put the
toilet has the history sharp thing yeah
the juicer that you usually take a lemon
and you know juice with you you know you
put in the middle and that's in the
toilet and I just don't want to know how
that works
do they get through there just kind of
start like do they have help do they
have someone turn them around that's you
know that you know what they do they
turn they turn and push oh I like it
let's get one installed sweetheart
you're wearing yellow yeah you yeah you
get on that get on the toilet yeah well
my god yes such a good idea
she's gone why she always in these now I
don't know it's almost like her husband
asterism yeah an old wooden ass even
when she's like I don't want to it's
like she's just doing it so that you'll
insist more to make it look like it's
your idea when yeah it's her it's it's
not working Jory and the feeling this
one one of the way to work
why is she doing about toilets I think
she just choose yourself that's what a
choosing Jory sounds like she will not
be returning